HAS THE ADMINISTRATION WORKS TO
DEPORT THOUSANDS OF MOSTLY
HAITIAN MIGRANTS IN TEXAS MORE
THAN 20,000 PEOPLE ARE NOW
REPORTEDLY GATHERED IN COLUMBIA.
THEY WILL SOON BE HEADED TO THE
US.
THEY ARE REPORTING THEY ARE
MONITORING THIS AS WELL AS
GROUPS OF ABOUT 1500 MIGRANTS
AND 3,000 IN PERU.
THE PRESIDENT IS FACING
CRITICISM FOR NOT DOING MORE TO
ADDRESS CERTAIN.
MEANWHILE THEY ARE BEING PRESSE
ON WHY FOREIGN NATIONALS ARE
REQUIRED TO BE VACCINATED BUT
MIGRANTS ARE NOT.
HERE WE ARE TALKING WITH THE
PRESS SECRETARY YESTERDAY.
>> WHEN THEY WALK ACROSS THE
COUNTRY DID SOMEBODY ASK TO SEE
THEIR VACCINATION CARD?
>> LET ME EXPLAIN HOW THE
PROCESS WORKS.
AS INDIVIDUALS FROM ACROSS THE
BORDER THEY ARE BOTH ASSESSED
FOR WHETHER THEY HAVE ANY
SYMPTOMS IF THEY HAVE SYMPTOMS
THE INTENTION IS FOR THEM TO BE
QUARANTINED.
THEY DON'T INTEND TO STAY HERE
FOR A LENGTHY SEGMENT OF TIME.
>> IS SHE MAKING ANY OF THIS UP?
THEY DON'T INTEND TO STAY HERE
LONG.
THERE IS JUST SUCH A LEVEL OF
DELUSION.
IT IS SO DISAPPOINTING BECAUSE
IT DOES NOT HAVE TO BE THIS WAY.
NOW HE PROBABLY HAD HIS PEOPLE
IN WORSE CONDITIONS THAN THEY
WERE IN.
>> HAITI IS NO PICNIC BUT NOW
THEY COME HERE AND THIS IS NOT
THE LAND OF THE FREE THAT THEY
HAVE HEARD ABOUT.
BY THE WAY MARSHALL WAS OFF ME
YESTERDAY AND SHE SAID SOCIAL
MEDIA IS PLAYING A HUGE ROLE IN
THIS.
TAKING AN AIM AT THEM FROM THE
HILL THEY ARE GETTING READY TO
HAVE A HEARING.
THIS STUFF IS BEING SPREAD IN
REACHING THE CITIZENS THAT THIN
THEY SHOULD COME.
WHAT THEY HEAR IS THE LOUD
MEGAPHONE THAT'S BROADCAST WITH
OUR PRESIDENT OF US SAYING YOU
CAN COME.
SAYS IF HE WAS ANSWERING A
CAMPAIGN PROMISE TO THE
PROGRESSIVES.
WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE?
HOW THESE THINGS THAT NORMALLY
HAPPENED IN THE DARK ARE
HAPPENING IN THE DAYLIGHT.
WE ARE DEPORTING THESE PEOPLE
AND IT'S A TERRIBLE LOOK.
JASON WORKS WITH THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND HE DOESN'T HAVE A
VOICE NOW.
>> IN THE GREEN LIGHT THAT BEEN
AMPLIFIED ON SOCIAL MEDIA IS
ONLY SURGING NOW.
BECAUSE MANY OF HIS MIGRANTS
HAVE BEEN IN COUNTRIES FOR THE
LAST YEAR OR SO BECAUSE THEY NO
LONGER HAVE TO REMAIN IN MEXICO.
AND WE HAVE A SOUND BITE FROM
OUR PRESIDENT AND WE CAN GET
YOUR REACTION ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF WHETHER WE BELIEVE ANYTHING
HE SAYS WE WILL TAKE A LISTEN.
>> IT'S UNDER CONTROL.
WE ARE GOING TO GET THIS UNDER
CONTROL.
>> SIMPLY AMAZING.
AS HE SAID WHAT IS HAPPENING ON
THE HILL THE SENATOR IS
TESTIFYING ABOUT HIS PLAN.
WHEN IS THIS PLAN GOING TO STOP
WORKING?
THEY SAID THAT THIS IS WORKING.
HAVE THE AUDACITY TO MAKE OUR
ALLIES THE BORDER IS NOT OPEN
BUT MIGRANT CROSSINGS ARE AT A
21 YEAR HIGH.
14,000 WAS THE HIGH NUMBER AND
YOU CAN SEE THE HUMAN EXCREMENT
HALF THE POPULATION AND WE HEAR
THEY AREN'T INTENDING TO STAY.
THEY TRAVELED THIS FAR TO BUILD
TENTS.
THIS DOES NOT MAKE SENSE AND
WE'LL SEE HIM LYING.
IS FROM AN ADMINISTRATION THAT
SEEMS TWO ONLY PRIORITIZE THE
PANDEMIC.
THEY ARE REFUSING TO VACCINATIO
AT THE RATE OF MISSIONS AS ABOV
8 PERCENT.
PUBLIC SCHOOLS WERE SHUT DOWN A
3 PERCENT.
THE POSITIVITY RATE IS UPWARDS
OF 15,000 FOR EXAMPLE.
THESE NUMBERS ARE TRULY
TERRIFYING.
IN THIS ADMINISTRATION IS ONLY
LOOKING AT IT AS THE PEOPLE ARE
REPUBLICANS.
ME BE VERY CLEAR.
IF YOU ARE AN AMERICAN CITIZEN
THE PEOPLE AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER ENTERING THIS COUNTRY
THERE IS NO RESTRICTION.
THERE IS NO VACCINE REQUIREMENT.
THIS SHOULD DRIVE THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC CRAZY.
THERE IS A DOUBLE STANDARD.
IT'S A THIRD WORLD COUNTRY DOWN
THERE.
I SUBMIT TO YOU ANOTHER COUNTRY
THAT LOOKS LIKE THIS.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS STRICTLY
LYING TO THE PUBLIC.
I GUARANTEE YOU THE ONLY REASON
THEY WON'T DO ANYTHING IS
BECAUSE THEY ARE AFRAID.
AND I THINK THEY ARE AFRAID OF
THE SOCIAL LEFT.
WE HAVE A VICE PRESIDENT THAT
HAS REFUSED TO HOLD A PRESS
BRIEFING AND VISIT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
REFUSING TO EVEN TAKE QUESTIONS
FROM REPORTERS.
ALL OF A SUDDEN AGAINST THIS
LANDSCAPE SHE IS NOW AGREED TO
GO ON A TALK SHOW.
WE NEED A LEADER NOT JUST A
TALKING HEAD.
>> SHE DECIDED WHICH WILL PULL
TEAM WAS GOING TO GET THE BALL
FIRST.
SHE ATTENDED A COLLEGE BALLGAME
OVER THE WEEKEND